hey John Matt how you doing I'm doing
well how are you I'm good so everyone
we're live this is got your labs first
google+ hangout and we're here this
morning on the west coast to talk about
mat Honan epic hacking on august 3rd
Matt your Apple ID was hacked a couple
of hackers team together and through
social engineering were able to convince
Apple and Amazon tech support to provide
the right information that would
ultimately allow them to get into all
your cloud accounts which were sort of
daisy chained together so I don't think
we need to go into all the details of
what happened we've covered it on wired
and Matt you had your own video that's
posted on wired as well so today we're
going to share some audience questions
that were sent ahead of time and i'm
just going to fire them at you matt and
here these are questions these address
topics that maybe we haven't delved into
too deeply an existing coverage so the
first one came from a comment to an
article an invitation article we posted
and this one is from jubilee BZ and the
person's question is what is your
opinion of cloud safety now that someone
was able to remotely wipe your personal
laptop I really think now that if four
counts of four that are storing our
personal information our personal data
especially stuff that's very secure or
that's very private like email it's
almost irresponsible of companies who
are doing that to not have security
mechanisms that at least have some form
of double augmentation double two-factor
authentication like a like Google's or
Facebook swear you've got you know
something you know like a password maybe
some of you you own like a phone I know
a lot of stuff is there's already a
movement towards biometrics there's
already movement towards you know using
things like key fobs that you know you
have to have that will communicate with
you but basically my opinion of cloud
security is that if it's just a single
pass
bird it's broken so from a big meta
perspective does the cloud give you
pause now because a lot of pundits out
there sort of indicted cloud as a
singular technology and that in general
the others almost advise that if you
really want to be careful you have to
store locally and the cloud is bad I
mean so I agree with one part of that I
agree that like if you really want to be
careful this is something you know
someone else asked us about this you
have to store locally like one of the
questions we got was what's young we can
get it up what my top priority is for
securing my stuff and is that you need
to have a local and online backup um if
you've got your data locally there's no
way I mean if you got a locally anal and
you know the redundant online copy of it
you're in control of it uh when the
problem is when you're not in control of
it you know the problem comes up when
someone else is in control if it went to
companies in control of it and they have
a bad security policy that you may not
even know about so getting back to kind
of your point the very circuitous matter
i think that um you know that III don't
think that it's a problem with the cloud
per se I think there are security
problems and I think that a lot of those
security problems are due to basically
you know accounts being susceptible to
social engineering to other weird
techniques that people can use to call
up and sort of trick tech support and
letting into your account I don't think
that's necessarily problem with with the
cloud it's the same thing people have
done you know I've been doing it banks
for you know forever it's it's you know
it's not like social engineering is new
right so a perfect segue to a question
from this came to our tumblr and it's
from someone named matt with 2 t's Matt
so how do you think Amazon and Apple
should improve the security of their
account so they already made some
changes in you know retro actively to
close the social engineering security
holes that allow the hackers to get into
your account but have they gone far
enough and if you were to take two steps
ahead what would what's the
vice to the Amazons and apples of the
world so it's interesting you know
neither one of those companies will say
publicly exactly what they're doing you
know amazon says that it's closed the
particular exploit that allowed someone
to get into my account which is adding a
credit card number of bogus credit card
number them to an account and then vo
the phone then calling back and giving
that credit card number to get a
password reset an apple has put a
temporary hold on issuing password
resets over the phone we don't know for
how long we don't know what their new
policies are going to be but I I think
that any policy that you've got is going
to be probed extensively by people by
hackers by social engineers whatever you
want to call them who are you know you
put a new policy in place and people are
going to try and get around that's just
a fact you know and and certainly Apple
and Amazon aren't the only companies
that have this problem we're going to be
looking at some more next couple of
weeks here but you know I think that you
know one thing that those companies
could do in particular to improve the
security of their accounts is set up
multiple sort of levels of access you
know Apple in particular I don't think
the same password that you use to buy a
single off of itunes or a ring-tone you
know should be the same password that
someone can use to wipe your devices
remotely um I also think that you know
especially with the remote wipe and the
find my stuff which you know also has a
level of privacy implication if someone
is able to get into your account and see
where you are based on where your
devices are I think there needs to be
another layer of security there that
doesn't exist currently I don't know if
that's a you know a second second
password and another pin but certainly
it needs it needs more than what it's
got right now I'll be very interested to
see what what they announced when they
write make no difference yeah it's
pretty clear they're they're making
trade-offs between convenience and
security and so some of the things
you're suggesting would add that extra
level but they also know the users don't
want to go through that the rigmarole of
that many more passwords and that really
is where a lot of the
lies exactly i think that that's the big
trade-off its security versus
ease-of-use it's you know okay well it's
a lot more convenient to have your
credit cards stored on some web server
somewhere so you don't have to enter it
every time you can just you know it's
more convenient for you it's better for
the company because you can just hit a
button that says buy instead of you know
going in and having a punch in your 16
digits and your security code and your
expiration date every time but the
problem is that you know if once that's
set up the onus is on the people who are
taking and holding that information to
make sure that it's very secure and that
you know if you're going to offer that
ease you've got to come you've got to
really bring the security as well right
let's get back to the the audience
questions this is also from tumblr it's
from a handle a Zach door so if you're
just to pick one one security measure
what is the number one priority for
securing your digital existence is it a
password is it is it delinking deep
daisy chaining your your various cloud
accounts um I'm actually gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna waffle and pick two uh but I I
think but I mean eyes because I think
that an essential part of security is
something that I wasn't doing which is
making regular backups and so I mean
that's not necessarily a security
measure in terms of keeping people out
but it will keep your data safe if
you've got redundant backups but the
number one security measure one of the
big security measures that I think is
important is to is yes exactly is to
unlink all these accounts you know I had
my once someone is able to get into my
apple ID account which was my also my
you know email account that my backup
email for basically everything they were
able to go everywhere else they could
get into my google via that they got
into Twitter and you know I think it's
pretty important to have and I'd know
this is something I never really thought
about before I think it's pretty
important to beat to have some some form
of private secure email that's not you
know that's not linked publicly that you
don't use to communicate with it's not
on your website it's not you know some
something that people can look up and
find easily about you shouldn't be your
name it should
you know you should have it you should
keep that thing secure and don't link it
to other don't you know don't make point
a get to point B get to Point C a good
point D right someone related so this
question is from let's see this is
actually a question in one of our
article comment threads it's from jaded
Fox why weren't your reset emails going
to a service you control you own the
domain empty age com if you have an
email setup with that sending the emails
to that would have prevented show social
engineering into that mailbox since you
would be the admin you know the simple
answer is I don't have email setup with
that domain I have run a mail server in
the past with a different domain and I
just you know I just wasn't doing it I
just you know it's not that much of a
hassle but it is a little bit of a
hassle and a little bit of a hassle a
lot of the stuff that happened to me was
preventable because I I wasn't willing
to do these little hassles like backing
up like an abling two-factor
authentication I mean things that I
should have done you know setting up
mail servers not something most people
were gonna do you know they're not I
mean they're a while I wish that I had
done that and he's absolutely right it
would have you know it would have
prevented all this stuff from happening
I could've um I uh you know I I just
don't think that's a realistic thing
that most people are going to do and to
me like it's the thing about what
happened it's interesting to me is not
what happened to me personally it's that
you know these systems were in place
that created this you know that may may
this possibility of a failure and you
know I think going back to that security
versus ease of use of you know if if
things aren't easy people won't do them
you know and right that's so that
statement right so the challenge becomes
how do we convince people to do them how
do we convince them that the security
measure that extra bit of inconvenience
you take today will pay off dividends
tomorrow and this this topic is is
expressed in a tangential way from
commenting from sally j and so it's it's
sort of a trippy question but but bear
with me if
you could call yourself with a magical
time machine phone with the limit of 30
seconds or maybe just a minute to talk
how would you convince yourself to make
backup copies of the photos and store
them somewhere offline so what's that
what's that dialogue that that you have
with your reluctant friend or your wife
to convince them that they have to be
more secure for me i mean i think these
you know what happened to me obviously
was was pretty crazy but you know I
could have lost all those photos in
another way i was at drivesavers and the
way getting Mike getting my my drive
worked on and they were covering my data
and the way most people lose data is via
a hard drive crash or some sort of you
know most people are losing data from a
hack they're losing data from a hard
drive crash or from you know some sort
of damage to the machine itself and if I
was going to make a phone call I would
say you need to think about having all
these pictures on your machine you don't
have backups of anywhere else and what
happens if you spill your cup of coffee
on it in the morning you know because
that you know if I'd done that I would
have lost the pictures and um you know
that's something I guess I certainly was
aware of but I just hadn't considered it
as a real possibility and I you know
I've the not having a backup was such a
bad idea there's so many ways it can go
wrong but like just if you can kind of
drive home that point of like what
happens if you spill coffee on your
keyboard I think I think that's
something that a lot of people can
relate to right so you and I are tech
journalist and a lot of our friends our
tech journalists how many how many
people in your network which is
extensive and you're very connected and
their tech savvy people how many people
do you think have actually changed their
own personal policies who've made
backups who've created different
passwords for all their accounts all the
smart things we're supposed to do as
your experience spurred change among
your friends I mean so I uh I one
thing's been very encouraging to me is
I've seen person after person after
person that I know that I don't know
online in person telling me you know i
set up a back were of the backup system
i turned on two-factor authentication on
on gmail and face
look I've you know I've taken these
security measures that you said that you
should have taken before this happened
that's that's awesome but I think
there's all there's you know and I've
done those things and and I thought but
I think the problem is like you have to
keep doing them you know and that's what
I hope people do is that uh you know in
30 days when you have to get that you
know text message to your phone again
from google to keep the the two-factor
going and login again I hope people
don't turn it off you know I hope that
like when someone has to sit there and
wait for you know half an hour an hour
or more father while their system backs
up they don't just get frustrated and
say you know what I'll do this later
it's sort of like you know I don't know
if you've ever had um someone close to
you have a have a health problem like a
heart attack or or you know something
like that where it gets your attention
you say oh I'm not gonna let that happen
to me I'm going to go out I'm going to
run and I'm going to get in shape and
you go out and you run for a week and
then you then you you know you don't do
it anymore it's not just starting these
habits it's maintaining them that's
important that's that's the real
challenge okay this questions from
Twitter well there's sort of two
questions the handle reliability asks do
you still love apple and then i'll just
add in another question from a different
reader going forward will you put as
much faith in apple the experience the
person is saying writing the experience
has left me questioning whether it's
smart to have everything i own be
apple-related so what was your hack sort
of an apple ecosystem hack um I mean
certainly the device wipes i were an
apple ecosystem hack as to whether not i
still love apple i mean i would say that
I've never loved Apple you know
certainly not the company um I think
Apple makes great products they make
really fantastic high-quality well
designed products with with typically
very good user interfaces and one of the
things they always focus on is making
things easy and I'm very disappointed an
apple that they made getting password
resets as easy as they did maybe that
was done you know to sort of like make
it easy for their users who had a
problem
but it was too easy and wiping a
certainly remotely wiping devices like
computers is too easy right now so I'm
very disappointed in apple and I'm very
uh you know i I'm I'm very shocked that
these systems were better thought out
before they're put out there in the wild
I certainly have come across many other
people who've had their devices wiped by
someone else by malicious individual
interestingly it's been in cases of like
a divorce sometimes when you know your
your your ex has gone in and you know
get revenge kind of wiped your stuff
going forward well I put in as much
faith in Apple absolutely not no I will
not and I you know I gotta say I'm
really looking forward to Windows Phone
8 and Windows 8 and I'm still going to
use what i consider to be the best
solution for me at all times whether
that's not gonna hold a grudge like I'm
never using your stuff again but I you
know if that's Apple if that's if that's
windows if that if that's you know a
Chromebook at some point in time I mean
I'm going to use whatever whatever I
think works best great okay so final
question did you ask the hackers how
many other people they had done this to
and whether they thought about the
impact on other people I've asked both
of these questions I until very recently
I'd only been in touch with one of the
two I got the other one kind of popped
up day before yesterday on Twitter and I
confirmed with the first guy that this
was this was the second one and I
haven't been as much touch with him the
second part of that question if I asked
what they thought about the impact I
have and their answer was was basically
no they haven't um that's the first part
how many other people have done this to
I haven't ever really been able get a
straight answer on that or what I would
consider a straight answer on that you
know I mean they it's it's not it's not
something that i found a phobia
particularly willing it was the one of
the one of the guys particularly willing
to talk about you know i certainly think
that he feels a lot of remorse what
happened in my personal situation
whether or not he's done this before I
mean it would be hard for you
to imagine that he hadn't you know
gotten into an apple ID before given the
level of knowledge he had about it but
uh you know he hasn't directly admitted
that to me right one of the things I've
that sort of caught my attention as
you've been covering it and I've been
working with you on the coverage is that
there is there there's a lot of there's
a lot of data out there and i'll use the
Sturm broadly best practices about
social engineering and so people are
looking into the tech support systems of
large companies and they're figuring out
where the security holes are and how
they could socially engineer a tech
support person and there's different
holes for every company and so as you
and I have talked about your hack I
think we're both learning a lot about
this underground if you will and it's
it's really interesting from a tech
perspective but also it's a wake-up call
that that this happens yeah I mean I
hope that uh you know I mean I
specifically called out Apple and Amazon
in the story I wrote but it's clear that
this is a far bigger problem than Apple
and Amazon you know and I really hope
that you know I don't know the the the
other large companies who are retailers
or who are you know email providers are
looking into their practices as well
right hey Matt thanks so much they said
up this was gadget labs first google+
hangout though there will be more and
next time we post a story asking for
comments please join in thanks a lot for
coming bye everybody bye